from Kevin my how will you ensure tax
incurred in the UK gets paid in the UK
and goes to those who need it most well
this is a really important question that
Kevin asks and there's nothing I think
that annoys people more than tax
avoidance by big companies now I think a
couple of things first of all we've got
to act internationally because that's
the best way of clamping down on this
but also we've got to be willing to act
on our own there are other countries
like Denmark and others who do a much
better job of actually clamping down on
tax avoidance by big firms now this is
in the news at the moment because
yesterday the chairman of boots start
telling people how to vote in the UK
general election well it turns out that
the channel of boots lives in Monaco and
is actually avoiding his taxes now I you
know I just got to say to you I don't
think people in Britain are gonna take
kindly to being lectured by somebody
who's avoiding his taxes on how they
should be voting at the UK general
election and you've now got this unholy
alliance between the Conservative Party
and people like him who are actually
saying that the country can't change I
think we can change the country and I
think part of my job is so we're going
to stand up to these powerful forces who
aren't paying their taxes or avoiding
their taxes because frankly they have a
responsibility here we talk a lot about
responsibility in our society I think
responsibility goes from top to bottom
in our country now how can we say to
people on benefits and others you should
be responsible with some of the top
people some of the most powerful people
in that country are avoiding their taxes
are not doing the right thing so it's
the piscina who's been trying to lecture
us about what we should be doing this
country frankly I think you should be
paying his taxes I don't want to come
back on that quite a statement there
James why don't ya are you stating
categorically that corporations economic
elites will be paying tax in the UK like
Amazon and Google absolutely gotta deal
with this you know we've got to deal
with this it's what they call this
profit shifting so they shift profits
and I mean you'll all heard of it by now
where they shift profits around the
world to avoid paying them in this
country and to sort of if you like put
them in countries where there are much
lower tax rate this is something the
world has got to get to grips with and
by the way there's a really important
point in this James which is this is
about businesses this is about decent
businesses
this country small businesses large
businesses who are doing the right thing
the vast majority are doing the right
thing and frankly there is not as we are
about the fact that you know there are
some people and some businesses who are
not doing the right thing and we've got
to clamp down on it Molly you've got a
point he just comes the front for us
please thank you do we not already have
systems in place to make sure that they
do pay their taxes in the right way it's
not happening Molly you know the actual
tax gap between actually what companies
should be paying or is being paid is
just going up enough enough under this
government we've got to clamp down why
do you think it's not being done
properly well if I think because there's
been a view and this goes to the heart
of this election there's been a view
that when powerful people or powerful
companies so this is the way it should
be that's the way what we should accept
and I just don't agree with that as
leader the Labour Party I took on Rupert
Murdoch of a phone hacking I took on the
energy companies over their prices
because I actually think you need a
prime minister who will actually stand
up and be counted on behalf of ordinary
people in this country and good to use
the line ah no pun intended ah you know
so I think that is a big change and that
is a big issue at stake in this election
to